i'm michaela peterson this weekend the
sunday times released a hit piece on my
dad
jordan peterson and me and it wasn't
just
in their magazine it was the front cover
i was focused on in there to an
uncomfortable degree
that article has led to other articles
and now we have the media
all over the world telling everyone my
dad has schizophrenia
turns out the entire mainstream media is
basically a tabloid now
which you'd think i'd have already known
dad does not just to be clear
and has never had schizophrenia
he had akathesia which is a very deadly
and severe side effect of some psych
medications
and originally started with
benzodiazepines used to treat insomnia
and depression
associated with an autoimmune disorder
he does not have academia anymore and
he's been off the meds
benzodiazepines since january 4th 2020
that we're causing it so if you're
worried about him he's okay now he's
doing better than he's done in two years
otherwise he wouldn't be able to produce
podcasts with matthew mcconaughey
russell brand etc and plan book events
in march
so that schizophrenia story is a
complete lie used to discredit him by
the mainstream media
and it's been really quite hard on my
family over the weekend
and it's still spreading we decided as a
family to talk
about akathisia because people don't
understand it and it's a dangerous
condition and we thought if we spoke
about it
maybe other people could avoid the hell
that nearly
killed my dad and the hell my whole
family experienced in the last two years
my dad has written an email response
that he sent to the times and i've
linked it below it's on his blog
he has no interest in addressing the
press situation by video
and honestly it would be a waste of his
time but i wanted to explain what's
going on
and i'm pretty angry about it so first
why'd we even do the interview with the
times clearly it was a mistake
we originally decided to do the times
interview because dad's publishers
suggested it
the times had been reaching out for
about six months and because we were
invited
with this super polite email i'll post
it up but here it is
i hope you're well i don't think we've
worked together before i'm a
commissioning editor at the sunday times
magazine in london
i wanted to get in touch about a
potential interview when the time is
right
with your father jordan peterson we've
been following a story closely over the
past weeks and hoping that he's doing
better
it's such an exhausting uncompromising
virus this was
sent in august after we had coved
it must be an incredibly stressful
period for you all when the time feels
right we would love to
send one of our writers to speak with
him for the magazine
i like to think we tell difficult
stories with generous space
time and objectivity we run long-form
features
telling the whole story rather than
short flashy headlines
the headline they published was jordan
peterson on his depression
drug dependency and russian rehab hell
the interview would cover his life and
career to date
family life illness recovery and
upcoming plans and projects for the
future
it would allow you to clear up any
factual inaccuracies that might have
been reported in the press
telling his side of the story as well as
celebrating his life and career so far
let me know what you think i've attached
some interview examples here so you can
get an idea of what it might look like
it would be great to talk
best wishes so i sent that email over to
the penguin publicist
to vet the times came off as totally
reasonable to them
and they thought it was a great idea and
we set it up for january
we figured perhaps if we got the health
aspect out of the way
then when his book beyond order is
published march 2nd
we won't have to deal with health
questions anymore given it's in the past
however things went completely sideways
they wanted serious details about the
health experience
now dad and i did a podcast in july
detailing the journey
in detail we decided i should describe
what had happened because i was there
the whole time
i was with him throughout it and i
remember it but much more importantly
it's absolutely miserable to go over and
dad's feeling better
and i didn't want some journalist poking
him
about things they don't understand i
wasn't supposed to be part of the
article
i was just supposed to give details
i was just supposed to recount the
health aspect of the last year
i told the journalist specifically um so
i'll give you
the brief story i've recounted it a
whole bunch of times to
every time we get a new doctor so i'll
give you the background and i wanted to
do it because
my dad is he's still not fully recovered
he's probably not going to be fully
recovered for another year to be honest
um and he's still extremely
prone to anxiety and so
any recounting of it is it knocks him
out for a couple days
dad was hoping i don't know what the
article is going to be like he's hoping
it's not going to focus
entirely on health i said that i read
the other stories and some of them were
pretty health focused
so we'll see what he says tomorrow
because he's trying to you know
get past this but we thought if people
understood what happened
and the reasoning behind things then we
could just let it be
it was like this happened don't do some
of these things
and if you are on these medications like
especially psych meds
and you're acatheisic and you weren't
before maybe look at the meds right
but people don't know about it and there
are some docs some specialists out there
that can help
if you know what the problem is um
but yeah ideally we'll just leave this
be and then dad can go back to
touring and writing and doing podcasts
and
being controversial and we can not deal
with
uh health for a while it's like my
entire life
but yeah reach out if you have any
questions
thank you very very much hey thank you
thanks we didn't want to talk about his
health too much we didn't really want
that to be a huge
focus we wanted to get past it
however i'm skeptical of mainstream
media
clearly not enough so i recorded the
entire interview dad did
and the one i did and they're up
completely unedited on my dad's channel
right now
it's just the audio unfortunately it's
called unedited peterson times interview
however it's three hours long and has no
video
and this press disaster needs to be
addressed i think
so i'm going to go through the times
article now and tell you guys where the
mistakes are
we can compare to what was said in the
actual interview as well
jordan peterson on his depression drug
dependency in russian rehab hal
the superstar psychologist scourge of
snowflakes
and his daughter michaela explained how
he unraveled
and their bizarre journey to find a cure
i'm not going to read the whole thing
because it's really long but i'll read
the i'll read the really
spicy parts i thought this was going to
be a normal interview with jordan
peterson
after speaking with him at length and
his daughter for even longer
i no longer have any idea what it is i
don't know if it's a story about drug
dependency or doctors or peterson family
dynamics
or a parable about toxic masculinity
whatever else it is it's very strange
okay so far that's not too unreasonable
it is very strange
then she goes in to describe who dad is
a clinical psychologist
a conservative superstar of the culture
wars born and raised in alberta
spent the first three decades of his
career in relative academic obscurity
turning out papers and maintaining a
small clinical practice all that changed
in 2016.
practically overnight the toronto
professor became a youtube sensation
posting videos and lectures attacking
identity politics and political
correctness
and dispensing bracing advice about how
to be a real man
so i haven't read this entire article
all the way through because i was
really upset over the weekend and every
time i read it i cried
i'm not exaggerating i'm not a
particularly sensitive person
and this was really upsetting so this is
the first time reading it all the way
through
so hopefully i don't get too emotional
his 2018 self-help bestseller 12 rules
for life and antidote to chaos has made
him arguably the world's most famous
and certainly its most controversial
public intellectual
i i don't think that's right i don't
think it was the book it was actually
the media and a couple of interviews
that made him the most controversial
public intellectual given the fact if
you actually listen to him
he's not very controversial
so then she you guys can read it you
have to read this article
um she goes on to talk about kathy
newman on channel four
okay so she goes she goes after the
kathy newman debate obviously
um and then goes if his rise to fame was
dramatic
what has happened since he disappeared
from public view 18 months ago sounds
fantastical
in his daughter's words it's like a
horror movie it was like a horror movie
it's been like two years of a horror
movie but
you know don't have any sympathy for
that a movie
in which her father gets hooked on
benzodiazepines
that's one way of putting it or you can
say formed a dependency because that's
what those drugs do
becomes suicidal misses the akathesia
part he didn't just become suicidal
he had a akathesia caused by the meds
and is hospitalized and then diagnosed
with schizophrenia
so that's what the mainstream media is
picking up on
the reason we pulled him out of the
hospital which we've made clear in the
podcast
is because when no one would diagnose
him with acathelia because the doctors
didn't know
didn't know what was going on so he was
misdiagnosed multiple times
misdiagnosed when we finally found a
competent doctor
he was diagnosed with agathesia which is
what i tried to make clear in the
interview because
lots of people with acatheia are
misdiagnosed and it kills them
so that's what happened to my dad he
never had schizophrenia
okay
this is good too against his doctor's
advice
the one that misdiagnosed him just the
random
doctor that misdiagnosed him she flies
him to russia to be placed in an induced
coma he emerges delirious unable to walk
and ricochets from one rehab center to
another
ending up in a serbian clan where he
contracts covid19
okay because people don't know the story
he
we went to hospitals in canada and then
the u.s
and then back in canada before we went
to russia because
obviously we were trying to stay in the
north american healthcare system and
you guys should listen to the interview
that we actually did actually i'll put a
clip up
well this is obviously i've talked to
various people about this and everyone
says
why on earth would a high profile north
american
i went to the best treatment clinic in
north america in connecticut
and all they did was make it worse
they were we were out of options like we
were out of options
my the the judgment of my family was
that i was likely going to die in
toronto
and so there again i mean lots of people
would say why would you sort of trust
the judgment although your family
members love you they're not trained to
qualify the medics
why would you why would you put yourself
in their hands and not the medical
professions
i had put myself in the hands of the
medical profession
and the consequence of that was that i
was going to die
[Music]
and we put ourselves in the hands of
medical professionals in russia too
so it wasn't like we were fleeing
completely fleeing from the medical
profession
i tried a slow taper on the
benzodiazepines and i couldn't do it
yeah you know and i went to this the
treatment clinic in in
on the eastern seaboard and they had
promised essentially
um a 12-week treatment program
and my impression of that was that at
the end of that 12-week period i would
be
free of benzodiazepines but that isn't
how it worked out at all
and i was i was on more medication when
i left that treatment center than i was
when i went in
when i asked if he feels angry with
himself for taking benzodiazepines
his daughter jumps in this also didn't
happen you can listen to the interview
jumps in arms waving hold on hold on and
tries to bring the interview to a close
here's a clip is there anybody that's
angry with yourself for taking
benzodiazepines
when now that you know how dangerous
they are
i wouldn't say angry um
i i it's not like i failed to see the
irony
that was another thing about this that
made it quite
still continues to make it difficult to
stomach
know i could should have i known better
possibly well i mean i did do my thesis
on alcoholism
although you know this isn't hold
you had a side effect from a medication
should you have known better that
benzodiazepines can cause academia in
people who take ssris
no you didn't have it like this this
wasn't benzodiazepine dependency
problem this was an akathisia side
effect from psych meds
right so like yes and no i couldn't have
known that yes that's right
um i'd have to say we have 10 minutes
before we have to wrap up
yeah i'm doing okay by the way yeah yeah
i know but
still or mom will kill me
if this was a movie its director would
unquestionably be the 28 year old
michaela peterson
i'm 29 but who cares about facts ceo of
her father's company
at least they don't say i do paid
consultations which they just stuck in
the original copy and
also isn't true
she and her husband appear to have
assumed full charge of his affairs so
before i'm allowed to speak to him i
must first talk to her
i wonder why someone who wrote this
article
wouldn't be allowed to talk to him
directly
because you're a human spider
oh i see she just doesn't like me
because she doesn't like the way i look
unrecognizable from the ordinary looking
brunette from photos just a few years
ago
michaela today is a glossy pouting
barbie blonde
and talks with a zealous spiky
conviction
of a president trump press spokeswoman
ah okay this is getting better
according to her website she has
suffered from juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis
an autoimmune disorder since early
childhood wouldn't which necessitated a
hip and ankle replacement at 17.
okay according to my website no i'm
faking it man
i'm faking it you got me needless to say
the medical profession does not why are
we even on my meat diet honestly i
shouldn't even be in here i don't know
why they're mentioning that i look like
a barbie but
i like to take care of myself what can i
say
barbie hair is getting in my eye
needless to say the medical profession
does not endorse this diet
nevertheless in 2018 her father adopted
it and within months declared it had
cured his depression anxiety psoriasis
snoring gingivitis gastric reflux and
even the floaters in his right eye
right eye just one eye i don't know
where these people are coming up with
this
he stopped taking the ssri
antidepressants he'd been on for 14
years
and proclaimed he was intellectually at
his best that's when he went on tour
he was in really good shape
like every medical autodidect
glad you can use fancy words uh i've
ever met
michaela rattles off pharmacological
jargon at 100 miles an hour
just because she doesn't know what she's
talking about doesn't mean i don't
sweeping from one outlander's tail to
another wow
with breathless melodrama that becomes
increasingly exhausting to follow
she wants to give me the nitty-gritty
nasty details yeah i wanted to do this
this was like the fun part of my day
of the past 18 months herself because
dad is still not fully recovered and
he's extremely prone to anxiety so any
recounting of the story knocks him out
for a couple of days
one true thing
after 80 minutes on zoom the one thing
of which i'm certain
is that we're as close to death as she
assures me your father repeatedly was
this is not the person i wouldn't trust
with saving my life
well that's fine i wouldn't be helping
anyway
i was trying to explain academia caused
by psych meds that kills people
so that it doesn't kill other people or
to try to stop that from happening
by early 2019 peterson was a household
name his book a global bestseller
when disaster strikes his wife of 30
years tammy was diagnosed with kidney
cancer
we did a whole bunch of research and it
was this extremely rare cancer that is
extremely deadly
we didn't just do the research they
diagnosed her with the deadly cancer and
they told us and then we did research so
it wasn't like
just in case that needs to be clarified
tammy suffered all kinds of surgical
complications and peterson spent months
at her hospital bedside terrified she
would die
that summer the doctor raised his
benzodiazepine dose but instead of
soothing him it seemed to only make
matters worse
dad started to get super weird it was
manifested as extreme anxiety and
suicidality
that's the akathesia if you guys know of
anyone who starts a medication
and gets panic and suicidal
it's probably the medication there's
something called academia it's not good
frightened he would kill himself
peterson transferred to a public
hospital in toronto in november where he
was diagnosed with schizophrenia
that's not what i said and that's not
what happened
agatha makes people suicidal it's this
crawling
feeling that's so bad you can see people
on youtube trying to describe it it's a
crawling sensation that makes you not
want to stop moving
um and so it's commonly misdiagnosed as
schizophrenia because
they don't know what it is um and in
order to treat schizophrenia you get put
on psych meds and that causes
worsening akathesia he was hospitalized
in december
and a doctor there said it could be
bipolar maybe it's schizophrenia we
should use
ect and dad
and our family said no because
obviously that's not the problem
so this is what she writes it's not like
we're uneducated this is me
according to her it's not like we're
uneducated in these things right
she says we kept telling them no the
problem was is medication
but they wouldn't listen to us so we
started calling rehab clinics around the
world
we rang 57 of them i don't say rang
and this one place in russia said yeah
we do detoxes
so we thought what do we do it's got to
be dangerous because no one else will do
it but my family agreed let's give it a
shot
yeah that's not exactly what happened
wow the toronto doctors were not okay
with it we had to sign papers taking
responsibility for whatever happened and
they were annoyed about it enough that
they wouldn't even give us his discharge
papers
which is not even legal it was a
complete mess okay explanation time
we pulled him out because they
misdiagnosed him and we went to get a
competent doctor
that fixed him sorry that that doctor
was in russia
it still worked and then
the center we used in serbia was a
neurological
rehab center and it's the one of the
best ones in the entire world
people don't understand that there's a
world outside of north america
at least this lady doesn't
she's so mad at me
so you guys have probably seen the
podcast and if you haven't the podcast
we did about this because it's over
but she recounts the whole thing uh
michaela contacted a clinic in serbia
we'd already met with a head doctor
there
by the way so it wasn't just like i
randomly contacted
a serbian clinic this like
top of the world private hospital and
flew her father to belgrade where he was
diagnosed with acathelia
there we go a condition of restlessness
classically linked to benzodiazepine
withdrawal
no it's classically linked to
psych meds finally michaela had found
doctors who corroborated her own theory
that's actually partly true i did find
doctors who corroborated my own theory
and the theory was right it was
akathisia
didn't she record this by now my head is
spinning the blizzard of obscure
pharmaceutical terminology keeps on
coming as michaela reels off the names
of more antibiotics fluoroquinolones
in antidepressants and antipsychotics
prescribed to her father
recounting her objections to this one
and that one it all
becomes a blur i was being recorded how
is this a blur
the long and short of it is that late
last year peterson flew home to canada
his akathesia the intense agitation and
restlessness
that makes him and everyone else who
experiences it suicidal has improved
significantly but not disappeared it's
disappeared now
no one can understand why it still
plagues him that's also not true
okay it takes a while to go away after
you have that kind of effect
it's like it's a delayed effect takes a
while to recover from it that's in the
medical literature
if you're smart enough to read it having
gone through several more doctors in
toronto michaela is currently
corresponding online with
thousands of acatheisia sufferers who
are telling me what worked for them
i had thousands of people email me after
we released videos about
about dad having academia saying you
know i hope you guys get through it it
almost killed me or i lost
somebody to it and telling me what
worked for them because doctors don't
really know how to deal with it
so i was collecting information because
i was worried my dad was gonna die
has she ever i wonder felt perceived by
like why is this
article about me has she ever i wonder
felt perceived by the medical profession
as the problem felt perceived by the
medical profession as the problem
okay i said completely yes 100
i've been problematic for a while
i am problematic
she starts to laugh i'm pretty pushy
when i think there's something wrong
she doesn't have any medical training
though i point out doesn't she worry
about the responsibility she's assumed
for her father's treatment
and i said because of my experience of
being ill i've done a lot of research
and i don't trust doctors because
doctors are just people right
according to her they're not just people
uh this opinion is not uncommon in north
america where surprising numbers regard
youtube as a viable substitute for
medical school
maybe because everyone's sick
whatever your opinion of peterson
however his scrupulous deference to
scientific data is indisputable
his public image is defined by scholarly
position
there's no precision there's no evidence
for that is practically his catchphrase
i am dying to ask him why he's submitted
to this medical circus
he's cured for god's sake orchestrated
by his daughter against his doctor's
orders who wanted to give him
ect when we speak the following day
that's electroconvulsive therapy by the
way that's zaps to the brain
so that you have seizures
i still can't tell if her father will be
cogent or incoherent
i don't know what to expect and michaela
will of course be monitoring our
conversation
michaela the evil overlord
peterson is as impeccably groomed
composed and meticulously
courteous as ever when he appears on
zoom a day later
he looks gaunt and pale though and i'm
struck by an overwhelming sense of his
vulnerability
good time to stab now as the professor
is
famously data driven i asked what
medical evidence was so compelling that
it persuaded him to detox in moscow
this is not what happened this is what
it says
he looks slightly blank i don't remember
anything
from december 16th of 2019 to february
5th 2020 he says
i don't remember anything at all he
reassures me that he did nonetheless
consent to being treated in moscow so
again i ask why
here's the clip so you probably she
tried to get treated twice
in the in north america first on the
eastern seaboard
at all do you even remember much about
those two
i don't remember anything about toronto
uh there's a i don't remember
from december 16th to february 5th i
don't of
of 2020 the end of 2019 the beginning of
2020 i don't remember anything at all
do you think you even did you know that
you were being that you were flying to
moscow to be poisonous
yeah so in real time you were fully
aware of it but you've got no memory of
it now
that's right yeah i'm curious about the
extent to which his mental health was
troubling him in the months and years
leading up to the crisis
crisis as in the side effect from psych
meds
so dad says well i don't think it's a
mental health issue i think it's a
physical health issue
i have an autoimmune disorder of some
sort and so and much depression
is autoimmune in nature now i'm confused
all over again
throughout all his medical ordeals there
wasn't even ever a formal diagnosis of
an autoimmune disorder was there
yeah there was michaela jumps in because
there was
in russia and in serbia fibromyalgia
this isn't an autoimmune condition is it
you can have blood markers like
inflammatory blood markers
that show autoimmunity and that can be
diagnosed as fibromyalgia
if he was diagnosed with schizophrenia
which he really
formerly wasn't he was certainly
diagnosed with fibromyalgia although
he's okay now right this was dr this was
medication
screwing with him then he starts talking
instead about post-traumatic stress
disorder can't imagine why
one of the markers for post-traumatic
stress disorder is derealization like
when the things around you don't seem
real
and i was in a constant state of
derealization from october 2016
until january 12th of 2021. being jordan
peterson he explains has involved five
years of untold pressure
i was at the epicenter of this
incredible controversy and there were
journalists around me constantly and
students demonstrating
it's really emotionally hard to be
attacked publicly like that and
that happens to me continually for like
three years
more more now dad more in 2017 200 of
his colleagues signed a petition at the
university of toronto to have me removed
from my tenure position
and my faculty association forwarded
that to the administration without even
notifying me
dad you don't have conversations like
that he's talking about people coming up
to him on the street
telling him that they've helped him or
that he's helped them
and he says you don't have conversations
like that that often outside of the
clinical sphere so part of what's
overwhelming to me is how it's direct
evidence of how little encouragement so
many people get
his face crumbles into tears they're
starving he breaks down
sorry he sobs i haven't done an
interview for a long
time he gets up to leave and returns a
minute later carrying a towel to dry his
eyes
okay that did that did happen to be fair
lucky this interview went so well or
definitely gonna be more
here's the clip you don't have
conversations like that
that often outside of the clinical
sphere and you certainly don't have them
repeatedly with strangers on the street
anybody to sub there's something about
it that's that's really
remarkably positive you know um
when i walk around well in any city in
some sense it's like i'm at home
because where people know me because
people say
on the street they say well uh really
nice to see you out
i'm glad that your health is recovering
it's like being surrounded by
well by well-wishers and by friends
and
i'm happy about it because
you know it's it's a great thing if
you're a clinical psychologist
to be able to extend your reach like
that
but part of what's overwhelming to me
is how it's direct evidence for how
little encouragement
so many people get they're starving
sorry i haven't done an interview for a
long time
fine of course
of course and things just fell apart
insanely
with tammy every day was life and death
in crisis for five months the doctor
said well she's contracted this cancer
that's so rare there's virtually no
literature on it
and the one year fatality rate is 100 so
endless
nights sleeping on the floor in
emergency and continual surgical
complications yes
he looks shell-shocked so i took
benzodiazepines
those drugs are notoriously addictive i
point out
he had surely heard enough horror
stories about housewives hooked on
valium in the 1960s
to be wary no i really didn't give it a
second thought they were prescribed and
i just took them
here's the actual clip or worried about
women in the 50s and 60s who got hooked
on valium and couldn't get over it and
well look when when benzodiazepines were
were first introduced they were touted
as an
almost completely safe replacement for
barbiturates
so no i really didn't give it a second
thought what happened was well partly i
was
i was you know my life was an absolute
whirlwind at that
at that time maybe they really were the
cause of all his problems which they
were
the more he talks though the more i
wonder whether toxic masculinity
might have been a culprit too
then she compares him to donald trump
because why not parallels with donald
trump come to mind
another unhappy man closed off from his
emotions projecting strong man mythology
while hunkered down in a bunker with his
family against the world
peterson's critics will undoubtedly
point out that he built an entire
intellectual philosophy upon the
principle that life is all about pain
and suffering
that the strong manly response is to
square one shoulders and battled through
it
not to take drugs numb the pain this was
an autoimmune disorder reaction lady
if you don't just like i hope you never
experienced that
and so dad goes no i never said that
look if you're a viable clinician you
encourage
people to take psychiatric medications
when it's appropriate what i really
encourage
in people is to understand that it isn't
useful to allow your suffering to make
you resentful
and believe me i've had plenty of
temptation to become resentful about
what's happened to me in the last two
years
there's another thing that actually did
happen when i watched the podcast he
made last june with michaela in belgrade
i'd tell him i thought he looked angry
and wonder who or what he was angry with
while pain will make you angry is his
response is any part of peterson angry
with himself for taking benzene
diazepines he hesitates
i wouldn't say angry but it's not like i
failed to see the irony
that was another thing that continues to
make it difficult to stomach you know
should i have known better possibly
and this is when i stepped in because
should he have known that
benzodiazepines can cause akathisia
nobody knows that including doctors here
hopefully they'll know more because
we're talking about it
not that the times is helping michaela
interrupts sharply
well but he continues i mean i did do my
thesis on alcoholism
she raises her voice and waves her arms
i said hold up hold up you had a side
effect from a medication should you have
known better
that benzodiazepines can cause academia
and people who take ssris
no peterson defers enunciating each word
she spells out
this wasn't a benzodiazepine dependency
problem
this was an akathesia side effect from
psych meds yeah i'm spelling them out
because she's so aggravating to talk to
i couldn't help myself like how do i
simplify this down
more her father nods yeah that's right
michaela checks the time we have to wrap
up
he glances up i'm doing okay by the way
and i said yeah yeah i know but still
mostly because i could see how this
interview was going to turn out
so then she asked wasn't it an
understandable response
to intolerable stress there's no way
akathesia is that michaela snaps that's
not what i said here's what i said
this is purely just about somebody
cracking under the pressure of life
is that a possibility that you've
considered well there's no doubt that
asia is then
that's right that well that's the basic
answer to that is that
like i didn't develop academia until i
stopped taking
tried to stop taking the benzodiazepines
so
you know peterson's wife is making a
miraculous recovery from cancer
she has recovered she's fully recovered
she's awesome
his greatest source of stress right now
is fear that the academia will come back
it's unbearable and there's always this
sense that you could
stop it if you just exercise enough
willpower so it's humiliating as well
i guess if you take sound bites from all
over the interview you could get to that
does it generate a self-punishing voice
in his head accusing him of being weak
yes definitely he worries that academia
must look like weakness to everyone else
too
it's certainly how it appears grotesque
for sure
this is why we're talking about it
because it's so awful
and if people still don't get it it's a
movement disorder
side effect from psych meds that doctors
are unaware of even though it hits a
number of people
like a large number of people who take
psych meds you can look it up on google
academia to see what it looks like it's
people kill themselves when they have it
because it hurts so much
so then she talks about him writing a
book it's still cruel
and rude
why didn't he postpone the book until he
was better he did postpone the book he
postponed the book about a year
i can tell you why i did it as in
writing it this is dad i can tell you
why i did it how i could do it
it was easy because the alternative was
worse not writing the book
staying at home and losing that part of
his life
as well as being incredibly ill he'd
lost a year to tammy being ill then a
year to his own
illness if i would have lost the book i
wouldn't have had anything left
i tell him i'm amazed he managed it and
he looks pleased
this woman this is dad so to the degree
that i can explain how i was able to
manage it i'm not going to talk about
willpower or courage i'm going to talk
about the lesser of two evils
and she ends it with except of course
that he has ended up framing his story
in terms of his willpower and courage
okay so that's the times article which
is pretty cruel
given the fact that well it's just it's
so biased i don't know how you can
as a media source write something like
this and release it
as the front cover and the fact that i
was
insulted so much i can't believe a
pouting
barbie blonde
there are lip injections women you can
get them too
trump press spokeswoman well
anyway i don't like people suggesting
that i'm faking my arthritis
like what a fun thing to do as a job
fake an autoimmune disorder and then
come up with a diet
to follow that's restrictive
and not get paid for it this just i
don't know that doesn't seem like a good
idea
anyway
so thank you for that deca
it can held you can tell by the comments
below your article what people
think of it after that
the daily mail published jordan peterson
claims he was suicidal and hooked on
benzodiazepines
after that new york post
publishes jordan peterson says he was
suicidal addicted to benzos and has
schizophrenia
then today the australian what
news.com.edu publishes sense of doom
jordan peterson dishes on severe benzo
addiction and schizophrenia
so these news articles are just taking
the times article and
rewriting misinformation based on it and
it's
really hurting my family i'm
not upset right now but i was
really distraught over the weekend okay
because recounting these events is
really stressful
akathisia is not to be taken lightly
my dad's better but we're trying to put
this behind us like he's producing
podcasts we're going to come out with a
couple more
just let it go and i hope other people
don't experience
this and if they do have these symptoms
hopefully they know how to talk to their
doctor about it
so then we have a couple of outlets the
post-millennial a canadian outlet says
media outlets falsely claim that jordan
peterson has schizophrenia
thank you very much blaze media
dr jordan peterson's family denies
misleading reports that he has
schizophrenia
yes this is true you can see the full
email
dad wrote linked below and on his blog
about his response to the times and
these news
articles i'll i'll post it up here but
you guys can read it he just told them
he couldn't believe what they were doing
i can't help but be struck by the vast
gap between what was offered and the
resulting interview
which no reasonable reader could
possibly consider
celebrating my life and career so far as
indicated by an overwhelming majority of
the readers of this piece
and what was done to my daughter who
uprooted her husband and small daughter
more than a dozen times to accompany and
care for me in four countries
in the last year while simultaneously
dealing with her own severe
health issues skeptically described by
your author
and the near death of her mother was
brutally unfair callous and cold
her illness thoroughly documented over
multiple years at the toronto hospital
for sick
children resulted in the shattering and
painful disintegration of her right hip
and left ankle
and their surgical replacement of both
before she was 17.
technically i was 17. anyway i'm not
going to read that because it's making
me cry but he just
goes on a rant too a rant a very
well-written
eloquent rant um pointing out
how unacceptable this is given the
manner in which you crafted your
invitation to me i can't understand how
you can in good conscious accept what
has transpired sincerely dr jordan b
peterson
these stories hurt people they're lies
i'm fairly resilient but this made me
emotional and very angry and i couldn't
sleep saturday night
and honestly if you want to get true
information watch long
form podcasts for me watch the podcast i
do
watch the podcast i do with my dad to
watch our interactions to see i'm if i'm
this
weird overarching controlling character
or not
don't take the opinions of some
resentful angrily journalist
watch my dad and listen to what he says
not the times not buzzfeed
directly information from him if people
are worried about
dad or my family please share the video
we need all the help we can get to
combat this kind of thing
i've got faith in the power of honesty
and the ability in people to see through
lies but sometimes some blunt
clarification can help
and i'll see you guys soon in the next
podcast i produce or dad will see you on
his channel or us together but we're
okay the article was
really upsetting but it's mainly
upsetting because seeing the true
malevolence in people is
really scary sometimes anyway
onwards and upwards podcasts are coming
out dad's book is
out in march march 2nd and it sold tens
of thousands of pre-sales already
that's linked below i've read it i think
it's better than 12 rules for life
and on that note don't [ __ ] with me i
don't take it lying down
see you around folks
you